[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Joe was
waiting in San Antonio Joe welcome to
the show what's Happening guys thank you
so much taking my call I love your show
you guys are incredible oh thank you
we're we're honored to have you how can
we help today I think this is a
no-brainer but I'm still gonna ask
because I'm old and
semile and I don't want to make a
mistake well you know you're self-aware
enough that tells me you're still here
with us
I just don't want to make a mistake at
my age I'm 69 years old my wife and I
are both retired we live off of Social
Security uh we have no debt at all my
house is worth probably
800,000 uh we have no credit cards no
car
payments we're dead free right right do
you have any
retirement uh no that's all we love live
off is of Social Security and how much
is that every month that's like uh 3,500
a month okay 3500 month no Nest Egg got
it well there's a nest egg but well how
much is it I don't touch it uh about
$100,000
okay okay and what's the question so so
what I want to do I have the opportunity
I live on two acres I have a big shop in
the back that I'm not using all and I
was thinking of converting that into
a what do you call it I can't think
little apartment can't think of the name
right now anyway so just adding on about
taking out oh I'm sorry what's that
again you're just adding on an extra
room yeah but it's not a part of my
house it's on my property but it's on my
shop in the back of the property okay or
or next to it one or the other
approximately 600 to 1,000 square feet I
haven't really decided okay but I want
to know since I don't want to test touch
that Nest Egg should I take a first lean
loan out on my Mor no way man
why would you do
that because I can get a write off I can
use no no Joe you know who says I'm
going to do it for the write off broke
people who don't understand how taxes
work you're going to put your home at
risk go into debt after being completely
out of debt at 70 years old for a write
off yeah you don't need it how much is
it gonna cost I how much is it gonna
cost give my brain straight what's the
addition gonna cost
what's that say what's the addition
going to cost you uh roughly between 50
to 60,000 and what's it going to do for
you yeah what's the purpose well they'll
bring in roughly an extra income um
anywhere between 12 to 1500 a month how
do you know someone's gonna pay $1,500 a
month for a 600 foot spot on a farm
pretty pretty proven by who uh it's
going to happen I'm not worried about
that Joe but think about this the Roi in
this thing let's say $1,200 a month 12
months a year let's say That's All Pure
net profit you never have in a single
expense which is a lie that's 14 Grand a
year so even then it's going to take
years to Roi on this 60 Grand purchase
uhhuh and you don't need it because
you've been saying you've been living
off your social social security just
fine yeah yeah and I think it's going to
cost more than that to get this thing up
and running I do too it may it just me I
mean Plumbing it may take around
electricity that's what I'm saying HVAC
but
yeah yeah exactly no I already done all
the figures and it's it can get up there
I mean if you had away if you had such a
big big equity in my house that's the
only way I can probably recapture some
of the equity I'm not going to lose the
house because I I've already done the
math kind of uh $50,000 is 577 a month
for 12 years here's the thing I'm not
really sure what you need the extra
$1,200 a month for unless he was going
to take that money and invest it and was
but I I think we're getting a little
Starry I Joe I'd back up I think the
reason you called was because you knew
deep down your heart this was probably a
bad decision and we were here to
validate that and now we're the Bad Guys
for ruining Joe's dream no we're the
good guys for keeping him in his right
mind that's the show